معنى منك يا ذا يورثات مستشار وصير الدفاع
الاوكراني استاذ يوري اسمح لي ان ابدا من
باخموت التي تحدث عنها اليوم الاعلام
الغربي بانها اشبه باحدى مناطق الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ما الذي يحصل هناك
وهل فعلا هناك تقدم للقوات الروسيه اثر
هذه المعارك الطاحنه
هنالك
شديده
الجيش الروسي الجيش
كل يوم همم
تشهد من اشد المعارك على الخطوط الاماميه
لنقدم
القرانيه في المحورين الجنوبي والشرقي الا
ان القوات الروسيه تضغط
وتتحاور مثل ضخمود مثل مارينكا اديسكا
وحول اوغلادور لماذا يعني هناك ضعف من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه بهذه المحاور وهناك
تقدم للقوات الروسيه فيها
مناطق ان احنا
جماعهنا المضاده منذ شهر اغسطس
حرارنا خيرسون الروس
به هجمات اليمن
البحريه الاوكرانيه تحدثت عن حامله
الصواريخ الروسيه والتي تتوقع يعني اثر
هذا الحشد الروسي هناك ان يكون هناك اسبوع
صعب لاوكرانيا ولهذه المنطقه المحاديه ما
الوضع هناك وهل فعلا نحن امام اسبوع صعب
هذا ما حضرت منه سلطاتنا
داخل اوكرانيا وعالميا نحن ندرك بان
المعتدي لن يتوقف
ونحن نتوقع
وتردي الى اوضاع ونحن ندرك همم
صاروخيه الجديده
حاليا
الخاصه
ونحاول استيعاده الكهرباء بعد انقطاعها
الوضع افضل الان ولكن لا يعمل المقبله قد
تكون صعبه واا نحن نعرف السفينه التي
ذكرتها
صواريخ نحن نستعد
ارهابي الصواريخ القادمه